c'est un sentiment anti français qui
gagnent du terrain dans le monde
musulman
les manifestations se multiplient comme
ici à gaza où des portraits des manuels
macron sont brûlé et piétiné
pour ce responsable du hamas des
associations de défense des droits de
l'homme doivent prendre position à
travers cette manifestation
nous dénonçons insultes fait prophète
mahomet et exigeons que toutes les
organisations humanitaires de défense
des droits humains et international est
une position claire envers le président
français est contre ces abus et attaque
contre la religion musulmane et les
sentiments de la communauté musulmane
manifestation aussi en israël devant
l'ambassade de france à tel aviv
à l'origine de ces tensions
grandissantes deux déclarations d'
emmanuel macron la première lors d'un
discours sur le séparatisme début
octobre et la seconde pendant l'hommage
national à samuel pâti mercredi dernier
nous porterons haut à la laïcité
nous ne renoncerons pas aux caricatures
au dessin même si d'autres reculs
l'islam est une religion qui vit une
crise aujourd'hui partout dans le monde
nous ne voyons pas que dans notre pays
c'est une crise profonde qui est lié à
des tensions entre des fondamentalismes
des projets justement religieux et
politiques qui on le voit dans toutes
les régions du monde conduisent à un
durcissement très fort conséquence de
cette montée des tensions l'hébergeant
sur les réseaux sociaux du hashtag
boycotter les produits français au
koweït et au qatar
une soixantaine de distributeurs ont
déjà banni les produits alimentaires
made in france comme les fromages
un coup dur pour la france alors que les
pays du golfe représentent en important
débouché pour les exportations
agroalimentaires françaises